Hey guys, Pete here. Today's Game of
Thrones Season 8 video will be about the
questions I have heading into the series
finale. this is it. this is really it. in a
few days there won't be any more Game of
Thrones. I'm pretty sad about it, and
things are really divided out there. I
understand that everyone is processing
the end in different ways and can see
the valid criticism that some people
are putting forward. at the same time I
find the negativity to be exhausting and
unhealthy. I believe that no matter how
season 8 went there were always going to
be problems because the books aren't
finished. it's a bad situation because
people care about this story and these
characters and they're having to see
things conclude without knowing exactly
how things will play out on the pages of
the books. it's the worst case scenario
for everyone, nobody wanted it to happen
like that I don't think. George RR Martin
didn't want it to happen like that.
HBO didn't want it to happen like that,
and definitely Dan and Dave didn't want
it to happen like that. so I could make a
whole video about this and maybe I will
but for now I want to get into what I'm
interested in and move away from the
negativity because, remember, everyone
deserves to have their own experience.
where we can all agree is that it sucks
that the end is coming. so, I recommend that
you just have your own experience and
watch it, feel it, process it how you have
to and don't let anyone else's opinion
shape your own. so the pictures came out
or should I say picture. there's
literally one and it's Tyrion so the
first question I have is what will
happen with Tyrion. we know he let Jamie
go in the last episode knowing that it
was the wrong thing to do but hoping
that everything would work out to his
favor in the end I actually liked the
scene with Jamie and Tyrion it was a
good moment to have between these two
characters reminded us of when Tyrion
had been sentenced to death after Oberyn
lost to the mountain and Jaime released
him so yeah this was a good character
moment but it's also definitely tied
into Tyrion's ending when you couple that
with Daenerys telling him that the next
time he fails her will be the last time
there's really no way that this can end
well. I suspect that Tyrion is gonna have
to do some maneuvering but as the way
things are now going into the episode I
think it's pretty safe to say that she
will want to
execute him, just like she did Varys and
we'll have to see what Tyrion does in
light of that. what about Davos? he
actually helped Tyrion by providing the
boat for Jaime and Cersei to escape in
personally i tend to think that nothing
is ever gonna happen to Davos but i
could be wrong
he did play a part in the scheme he is
Jon's closest advisor at this point but
to me he's still one of those characters
who can't die they need him after the
dust settles to help put together a new
government or whatever's going to happen
there so I tend to think that he'll be
okay but he may be implicated and there
may be some drama around that. the next
big question is one I talked about in my
trailer breakdown we see Arya at the end
of Episode five it looked like she might
be riding away and getting away from all
the violence and deaths once and for all
but then we see her return in the
trailer so has she changed her ways? I
think one of the best moments in episode
5 was the hound and Arya conversation
the way that we saw that he cared for
her and that he gave her advice that she
might actually follow because of their
relationship. it was touching it was
exciting I always wanted a twist for
Arya where she got away from being a
killer so what are we supposed to think?
I mean I think we're supposed to think
that she's gonna kill Daenerys, I'll talk
about that some more later. I think the
answer to this question though really
comes down to she's gonna be conflicted
after she decided to leave and not kill
Cersei she saw all the real horror of
war she saw real pain and suffering she
tried to help others so I think yes she
has changed but I think that there's a
conflict coming where she's going to
want to kill Daenerys and then she's
gonna have to make a decision when we're
talking about the Starks it's important
to bring up Bran I guess because he's
such a confusing part of the story at
this point it's hard to say what's going
on with him but the thing that stood out
in episode 5 related to Bran was that we
did see that vision play out we saw the
Dragons shadow on King's Landing
this has led to some people asking in
comments whether brand knew what was
going on before they went south based on
those visions I would say yes
he saw that stuff he should know
about it it brings up another question
of why didn't he do anything about it
but I don't think that's inconsistent
from what we've seen him doing from
interviews I've read from the actor who
plays Bran
he says that he's very careful with the
information that he shares with other
people like he doesn't tell people what
he knows because he doesn't want it to
affect the outcomes of things on some
level but on another level people could
use that information to their advantage
so yes the answer this question I think
bran probably did know but I'm not
really sure if it's weird that he
decided to let everyone go there anyways
and let that play out how it did another
big question I have is will there be an
epilogue and I think the answer to this
is also yes people are devastated with
Daenerys astern and we'll talk about
that later but it does at this point
feel like we're really getting a lot of
the bitter and not really anything that
feels good in the ending that it's gonna
make us feel that bittersweet feeling
that George RR Martin has said so many
times I think that the epilogue is
probably the best vehicle to give us
that I think we're gonna need to see
some things in the future to reinforce
that whatever happens with the person
sitting on the throne or the government
getting put into place we're gonna have
to see some of these characters that
like Sam and Gilly or kendry or
something like that where we see them
and things have gotten better as a
result of what happened with all this
pain and suffering that leads into the
next question which is who was Vera
sending letters to I've been seeing this
in my comments a lot well we can put
together there Varys was trying to
poison Daenerys we saw his little bird
he was telling her to go back but
Daenerys wasn't eating so he'd probably
want to send out letters to the Lords of
Westeros because if she dies then that's
already out there and if she finds out
what he's doing and executes him like
she did that would still be out there so
the Lords that we know of right now it's
a pretty small amount we know Yara rules
in the Iron Islands
we know Robin Arryn is still in the Vale
and we know that there's a mysterious
new prince in Dorne and that brings up
the next question who will rule in these
areas after things are said and done so
I didn't mention the north and the last
question because obviously they already
know about Jon's heritage but that means
we have the reach
no one's currently at Highgarden we have
the Riverlands there's no one there that
we know of we do know that Gendry is in
the Stormlands or he is the lord of
Storm's End at least at this point and
then we have the Westerland's which
tyrion would probably be in line to be
the Lord of Casterly Rock since Jamie
and Cersei both died but it's really
kind of hard to tell if this will play a
part like I said I think that we'll have
to see the ones that we know the named
Lords come come to King's Landing before
things wrap up Daenerys would call them
or if something happens to nurse then
there probably have to come for some
kind of transition anyways so they're
all gonna be headed there that leaves
room for us to find out who's gonna go
where of course bran could play a part
in that
if he gets hi garden from Tyrion that's
pretty up in the air though the
Riverlands could end up going to Edmure
Tully who we haven't seen for a while if
it's not him I don't know who it would
be
that would leave the Westerland's and I
don't know I think that just hinges on
what happens with Tyrion Highgarden is a
little bit up in the air too because
because Sam could be a candidate for the
reach since that's where his family's
from but based on what we've seen I
don't see bran going away quietly I
think he would push to have that go
through at the very least so there may
be a bit of controversy there and
everything obviously relates to Daenerys
and what's gonna happen a lot of the
discussion I see around Daenerys was if
she needed to become a villain I think
that's an easy question to answer for me
yes she had to become a villain because
it's essential to the endgame there's
another question of did they have to go
as far as they did and have her kill
civilians this is a lot more complicated
I think it's definitely in Daenerys his
wheelhouse to do this I think it's
historically things like this happen at
times of war as well I want to say that
they could have set it up better but
there really isn't a better way that it
could be set up is there a good way to
set up an unforgivable act where lots of
innocent
we'll die I mean if the point is that
she has to become a villain because
that's how the story ends I think that's
what people really have a problem with
they have a different idea of how they
wanted her story to end. yeah it will be
more nuanced in the books
there will be point-of-view chapters but I
just don't think there's any other way
you could wrap up the story without her
going to the dark side and I think it
has to be clear that this fire and blood
side of her is incompatible with being a
ruler if there's any chance it can be
justified away like what she does if she
just kills Cersei if she just destroyed
the Red Keep then I think when she has
to die later on it doesn't really hold
up I think there would be a lot of
people who would be equally unhappy that
she was killed because they would be
able to work out a reason of why what
she did was justified based on what they
know and like about the character so
that being said what will her plan be I
think that she'll try to exert her power
there's a chance that she may realize
the horror of what she's done like I
think it's a heat-of-the-moment thing
and I doubt that we would see her in the
next episode talking about how cool it
was what she did I mean I think she's
gonna justify it but I hope that we'll
see some internal conflict there I had
to do this but how do I live with who
I've become by doing it and all of it
leads to the question of who is going to
kill Daenerys because with one episode
left I don't think there's any chance
and this has been my position for a long
time that you can't put the only person
that has the nuclear bombs on the throne
and make it a good story it just doesn't
end right that way for me anyway so
they're setting it up they had four
people in the trailer other than
soldiers they had Arya they had Jon
they had Davos and they had Tyrion.
Tyrion has killed before but I think
it's more in line for his character to
try to find a different way to get out
of the situation he's in I think he's
the least likely Davos is also unlikely
that would be a twist if Davos was the
one that killed Daenerys at the end but
I don't think that's where they're going
and that leaves the two kids from
Winterfell when you got Jon Snow and we
got Arya and I like arias
coming back to humanity so much I'm
really gonna be disappointed if it's her
was the way we've seen things play out
there's obviously going to be the end of
the Targaryen and the rise at least of
something out of the north so I feel
like if Arya kills Daenerys it's really
a bummer ending to her story and that
only really leaves Jon. that probably
has the most impact. that's probably the
hardest to watch, he's probably the
character that would be affected by it
the most I do believe he's gonna end up
in the north after all he's been through
and outside of some political
maneuvering from Sansa working with the
other Lords to come in and take Daenerys
out. after episode five everything is
really pointing towards John being the
one to swing the sword I don't think
that Daenerys his turn is the third
shocking thing that we've all been
wondering about the thing that George R
Martin told the showrunners a few years
ago I think that they probably always
would have known that Daenerys was going
to go in this direction I think since
George was more involved early on he
would have explained this to them so
that they could set things up properly
so this feels a lot more like it could
be that third shocking twist I've never
thought that John would sit on the
throne either I thought that seemed
pretty unsatisfying as an ending so if
it ends this way it kind of makes sense
it kind of puts Jon in the place where
he provides the balance we know that
doing the right thing is a big part of
his character he got that from Ned so I
think him doing something that he would
never do otherwise but has to do for the
greater good makes a lot of sense for
him so let me know what you think and
that brings us to the last question and
that's what about Drogon? Drgon is not
easy to take out there's some logistical
issues with that if Daenerys dies
what happens to Drogon? there's always
been this idea of a balance of Ice and
Fire
and the White Walkers are gone the magic
has receded on the ice side of things
the characters that are essential to the
story that were followers of the Lord of
Light and who were bringing people back
from the dead and doing actual magic or
where does that leave Drogon I mean I
always thought that they wouldn't make
it out but now that they've been through
the battle it's a little bit confusing
as to what will happen with him I guess
he could just go away there wouldn't be
any reason for him to hang around but
that's kind of unsatisfying he could
come back at any time and just burn
random people so let me know what you
think about that because I really don't
have an idea of how that is going to
play out
and that's about it for today guys I'm
interested to see what you guys think
about all these questions I will have
some more videos coming soon this week
leading up I had some family stuff going
on back in the u.s. yesterday so that
made it so that I couldn't make a video
but I should be back in making more with
no problems going forward let me know
how you're feeling what you want to see
how do you think things are gonna play
out please like the video if you enjoyed
it please subscribe to my channel if you
haven't already thanks for watching I'll
talk to you soon